but not today
today
i just can't
say any traditional words
congratulating you
i just can't do it when we have so many
deaths so much grief
and suffering when we have an ongoing
war full-scale war terrorist war against
our people
people of ukraine the occupiers bombed
soon again
aviation with heavier bombs
never ever threatened russia
now they're turning it
they surrounded it
they cut off
connection
deliberately
cut off
water supply food supply
cut off electricity
and probably since
the
second world
because of dehydration listen to me
carefully
in 19 in 2022
a child
died from dehydration we are fighting
for 13 days now
hundreds
of cruise missiles
planes
helicopters
are attacking us yes we are destroying
them
although
over the last 13 days they lost a lot of
their planes
however they have enough missiles
carrying out terror actions they have
enough bombs to drop them on
for 13 days we only hear promises
for 13 days they keep saying to us
you'll get some assistance in the air
you will get the planes
we will get them to you
people die
and this is the responsibility of russia
of russian soldiers
of those who deliberately
destroy ukrainian people this is the
responsibility of the occupier but
also
the responsibility lies on those
who
cannot make a decision
for 13 days now somewhere in the west
those who didn't provide security to our
airspace
those who didn't make these
important decisions about
us
in particular about
a human humanitarian corridors
for our people in mariupol but all those
humanitarian
corridor arrangements did not work we
don't have any more time to wait people
in mariupol have no time to wait the
occupiers want us to die we don't want
our people to die
we provided
a humanitarian supply
to our people in
when they're trying to go through these
green corridors
everybody will see
everybody will
be able to
see what they're doing
and those
responsible for these actions
will be
prosecuted
we tried to arrange these humanitarian
corridors
not just for our people not just for
ukrainians we also try to arrange them
for um foreign students who study in
ukraine
what they did
make sure that these humanitarian
corridors are safe
[Music]
if the leaders of the countries are not
making the right decisions i will keep
calling on people of those countries
i will speak to the parliamentarians
countries in the world
michelle from european council
on the basis of humanity
and then we will see that the ukrainian
sky is safe that
the ukrainian towns and cities are not
surrounded anymore and that we can do it
all together
as humans
but if the world stays aside
they will just lose themselves because
all the
to have the right to live and we are
fighting for this right
and
glory to ukraine